احنا الصبح صاحيين على هذا الصوت صوت ضرب
النار الفارك ورد حجتنا اول حاجه في شبكه
كامله اتقطع منها الانترنت
فالناس دي مش بتقدر تتواصل الانترنت بيبقى
مكالمات بس واحيانا بتقطع الشبكتين
التانيين بيقطعوا عشان كده هتلاقوا انه
انا ما اعرفش ده هيوصل امتى او للستوري دي
هتبقى امتى بس
للاسف الشديد الشبكتين التانيين بيقطعوا
انا دلوقتي كلها بتخرج من الخرطوم
لاي حته اي حته بره الخرطوم يعني افضل
بكثير من الخرطوم
فاحنا شفنا ناس من من جاليات تركيه وناس
من جاليات هنديه بتتحرك وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه ما بتخرجش حد من الخرطوم بتخرج حد
من نقطتين بس من بورسودان ومن حلفه ما فيش
اي اجلاء حصل من الخرطوم الناس اللي بتبقى
عايزه تمشي من الخرطوم بتمشي على
مسئوليتها الشخصيه ببساطه شخصيه
زحمه جدا الباصات زحمه جدا وغاليه جدا
يعني فرق السعر احمد كان جاي ب 600 جنيه
15 دولار دلوقتي السعر 300 دولار عشان
يرجع مصر ويرجع وهم يعني فوق بعض في
الاتوبيس المفروض النهارده اخر يوم في
الهدنه اصلا ما كانش فيه هدنه ولا حاجه
لان كان في ضرب بس مش عارفين لو بعض
الهدنه الوضع هيبقى شكله عامل ازاي ما فيش
كشف البلد اي محاولات لتحويل اي عمله مش
مش موجود وما فيش بنزين يعني العربيات
اصلا تكاد تكون نادره في الشارع لان مفيش
بنزين حتى الشخص اللي ممكن يساعدك في اي
حاجه هو مش هيعرف يوصل لك الدعم سريع
موجود في الشارع عادي جدا موجود كمان
بالهبل ده معناه ان الخناق لسه مستمره
والخناقه مش هتخلص دلوقتي ناس كثير بتتكلم
انه الناس بتتسرق وناس بتتثبت في الشارع
لان طبعا ما فيش اي امان في الشارع خالص
وتقريبا مفيش حد في الخرطوم يعني احنا
تقريبا 15 20 بني ادم دلوقتي في الخطوه
الناس كلها بتتحرك بره الخرطوم للاسف
السوبر ماركت تقريبا
[موسيقى]